foreign
thank you
don't look a day over 21.
so happy birthday my friend um and I
also want to congratulate Scott Scott
this is your uh last day right in the
briefing room it's been a pleasure
having you here I know your new role and
congratulations on your new role as the
weekend host of all things considered
and consider this very exciting
listening while I'll be looking out for
your voice
um but today as I said is your last day
in a briefing room we will miss you and
uh around here and we wish you the best
in your next chapter so good
congratulations my friend all right so
just a couple of things before we move
forward with the briefing uh today we
launched invest.gov which shows how
President Biden's investing in America
agenda is bringing jobs and Investments
to every state invest.gov features an
interactive map that shows the 470
billion dollars and counting in private
sector investments in manufacturing and
clean energy mobilized by the
president's agenda it also shows the 32
000 infrastructure projects announced or
underway thanks to the president's
bipartisan infrastructure law
the president's investing in America
agenda is bringing manufacturing back to
America strengthening America's energy
security and Supply chains repairing
roads and bridges delivering clean water
deploying high-speed internet and so
much more
the site brings this the site breaks
this down by state and territory with
detailed stats about how the president's
agenda is rebuilding infrastructure
spurring Investments creating jobs and
lowering costs the bipartisan budget
agreement the president secured protects
these Investments that you just heard me
speak of they will continue to power the
economic progress we've made over the
last two years bringing more jobs and
opportunities to communities across the
country to highlight the impact of
President bides investing in America
agenda members of his administration
will fan out across the country later
this month for a second installment of
the investing in America Tour during the
Congressional recess around July 4th
now uh as just one example of investing
in America President Biden today
announced that the EPA is deploying 115
million dollars to help repair Jackson
Mississippi's water water system and
deliver clean water to the community as
you all may remember the city's water
system uh it was a cry it was in crisis
at some point last summer and even long
before then the people of Jackson have
lived under constant threat of boil
water orders this initial investment
will help stabilize and rebuild the
city's water system and it's part of the
president's commitment to ensure every
American has access to Safe clean
drinking water and finally I just want
to touch on a lawsuit that was brought
by big farmer challenging medicare's
ability to negotiate drug prices last
year President Biden signed into law the
inflation reduction act which for the
first time in our nation's history
allows Medicare to negotiate lower
prescription drug prices for seniors
caps the cost of insulin at 35 dollars
and requires prescription drug companies
to pay rebates to Medicare if any raise
their prices faster than inflation year
after year pharmaceutical Giants make
record profits as they charge middle
class families astronomical prices often
for drugs invented Generations ago for
decades of farmer Lobby has blocked
efforts to let Medicare negotiate lower
drug costs the Biden Administration
finally got it done President Biden took
on big farmer in legislative process and
he won
so now big farmer is challenging this
historic action in court the Biden
Harris Administration is going to fight
attempts to go back to the way things
were before
and so we are confident we will succeed
there is nothing the Constitution that
in the Constitution that prevents
Medicare from negotiating lower drug
prices anytime profits of the
pharmaceutical industry are challenged
they make claims about it hindering
their ability to innovate
not only are these arguments untrue but
the American people do not buy them so
President Biden is going to remain
focused on lowering America's health
care costs ensuring the benefits of the
of the law reach the American people uh
with that I have the Admiral my
colleague Admiral Kirby is here joining
us again today to talk about the news
out of Ukraine that you all have been
reporting on with the damn explosion and
so to answer some of your questions at
the top so we'll have us join as you
know we don't have a lot of time because
the president's going to be holding his
cabinet meeting so I'm sure Kirby will
be as brief as he can and take as many
questions
thanks Kirby
hey everybody
uh look I know there's been a lot of
interest in the destruction of the Nova
Kafka Dam in Ukraine and I wanted to
just take a minute to address it as you
might expect we've been closely
monitoring the impacts of that
destruction which has triggered massive
flooding in Ukraine and resulted in the
evacuation of at the very least
thousands of ukrainians
we know there are casualties including
likely many deaths
though these are early reports and we
cannot quantify them right now
we've seen the reports that Russia was
responsible for the explosion at the dam
which I would remind Russian forces took
over illegally last year and have been
occupying since then
we're doing the best we can to assess
those reports and we are working with
ukrainians to gather more information
but we cannot say conclusively what
happened at this point
we will certainly share more information
when we can what is clear and what we
absolutely can say is that the damage to
the Ukrainian people and to the region
will be significant this Dam which was
built in 1956 as part of the as part of
the kofka hydroelectric power plant
sitza stride Ukraine's danipro River
it's about 30 yards high and about 100
yards or so wide and the reservoir
protects holds about as much water as
the Great Salt Lake in Utah so that's a
lot of water
now that water helps Supply Southern
Ukraine including the Crimean Peninsula
as well as the zaparizian nuclear power
plant and I would add we were relieved
to see the statement today by the
director of the iaea asserting that
there was no immediate risk to the
safety of that plant
as I mentioned the dam also helps power
the kokova hydroelectric power plant so
in addition to loss of life and
livelihoods its destruction could very
well have a devastating impact on
Ukraine's energy security and it will
certainly have an impact on Ukraine's
Canal system
so we're in touch as I said with
Ukrainian authorities on how we can
provide assistance to the many
ukrainians who have been displaced and
forced to flee their homes for safety
we'll continue to work with humanitarian
Partners on the ground to supply Aid
Russia's unprovoked war in Ukraine has
had a devastating impact on the
Ukrainian people and brought terrible
suffering to them we will continue to
support Ukraine in any way we can
including through military humanitarian
and economic support as I said earlier
we'll monitor this as best we can we'll
stay in touch with our Ukrainian
counterparts and as we have more
information we'll certainly provide it
to you
you think the damage the structure could
have a counter-offensive operations
I think it's too soon to know to be
honest with you
um again I won't speak to Ukrainian
military operations uh in any way
whatsoever but right now the immediate
focus is rightly on all the ukrainians
uh whose lives and towns and Villages
are affected by this flooding and making
sure that they have the aid and
assistance that they need but right now
uh too soon to assess what what kind of
impact it's going to have on the
battlefield and one more in the Discord
leagues uh there's a report in the
Washington Post that the U.S has reports
that uh ukrainians were planning an
attack on the Nordstrom pipeline do you
have any comment on the intelligence uh
report of that and there are also
suggestions that Russia may have been
responsible for that you know why was
Russia initially figure-pointed in
Russia when the U.S might have had
information that ukrainians were playing
this so I'm certainly not gonna engage
in the discussion about the intelligence
matters here from the podium
specifically with regard to that
disclosure or any of the other and in
this case certainly not going to speak
to one that the Washington Post even
said was not corroborated by U.S
intelligence agencies now I think you
know there are three countries
conducting an investigation of the
Nordstrom sabotage and we called it
sabotage at the moment Germany Sweden
and Denmark those investigations are
ongoing and again the last thing that
we're going to want to do from this
Podium is get ahead of those
investigations
thanks
um John you just said that you can't say
conclusively what what happened at this
point with regards to the data you also
did note though that the Russian forces
have been occupying the stem since last
year so is your assessment at this point
that it is more likely than not that
Russian forces are responsible for this
rather than Ukrainian forces we haven't
made that determination and have you
determined whether this was an
intentional act again we're still trying
to gather information and talking to the
ukrainians about that and then thirdly
president zielinski said that he
believes it's impossible to blow up this
Dam from the outside by shelling for
example is that also the US's assessment
that this would have to be done from
from within hadn't come to a final
conclusion
thanks Kareen hi John a couple of
questions on Iran uh Iran launched today
A high carsonic ballistic missile that
can reach 1400 kilometer your assessment
of that and its implication to the
region and second since the British has
been very critical of the administration
it is just actually tweeted and he said
basically that the administration
doesn't have a clear policy towards Iran
and just let me just uh briefly just
tell you what he said he said Biden
Administration has been caught
flat-footed and has failed to articulate
a broader Iran's strategy and he's
referring to the exploration of the
ballistic missile
um at the U.N in October I wonder if
he's talked to the Iranians about that
because I don't think that they would
respond that we've been flat-footed I
think if uh if anything the Bible
Administration has been very clear very
concise uh and very firm on pushing back
on Ron's destabilizing activities in the
region to include the development of an
improving ballistic missile program I'm
not going to talk about these specific
reports of this uh this alleged
Hypersonic missile but we have laid down
very clear sanctions and other
activities to push back on what Iran's
doing in the region again to include
their ballistic missile program so I I
would not assess that the Iranians would
say we've been flat-footed or ignorant
of what they're doing in the region
thanks Kirby um you mentioned that we're
going to evaluate
um how we can assist Ukraine after the
attack on the dam
um speaker McCarthy on the hill today
said that it warned against trying to
use uh Ukraine funding to bypass the
defense
they're concerned that this damn attack
might accelerate the timeline for when
we need to when the the white house
needs to go back to Congress for
additional
um Ukraine assistance would
you have a general sense of what that
timeline is I know that in the past
you've said you still have kind of a
good amount of funding to work through
and it is the speaker or the speaker's
comments consistent with what you guys
kind of
so the level set we've been grateful for
the bipartisan and bicameral support
that we've had for Ukraine we have every
expectation that that's going to
continue we that's one two we've got
enough funds as I said earlier uh to
help support Ukraine on the battlefield
throughout the rest of this fiscal year
again we're just now assessing uh the
Damage Done by this damn explosion so it
would be important for me to try to
speculate as to what impact that might
have it's certainly difficult at this
early stage to see that there's going to
be an impact on supplemental funding
either this year or or going forward
into next year based on the uh on the
explosion but again we're in the early
hours here and we're going to take a
look at this and we've said before that
if we feel like we need to go back to
Congress for additional funding for
Ukraine we'll do that but we'll do that
at the appropriate time and now is not
the appropriate time to to have to have
that conversation with them
mental funding so that's that is that an
indication
leaker who is saying now that he wants
additional Ukrainian funny what I'm
saying is our focus is on executing the
funding we've got this fiscal year and
making sure Ukraine can succeed on the
battlefield and we're just not at a
decision point to talk about the need
for additional funding later on in
whatever form that might take we're
grateful for the supplemental funding we
got for this fiscal year terrific
support on Capitol Hill again both
Chambers both parties and we fully
expect that that will continue
especially on the NORAD intercept over
the weekend that plane stopped
responding to air traffic controllers 15
minutes after taking off but it took an
hour and a half until f-16s were able to
intercept it is that okay with you do
you think that the underlying protocol
needs to change here yeah I'm not going
to litigate the actual event over the
weekend here from the podium DOD we'll
take a look uh at the at the process
again as I said yesterday they responded
in a very textbook fashion here but I
also said they'll take a look at this
and if if they determine that there
might have been a procedure that needed
to be done differently they can speak to
them
John first back on the North Street
pipeline you say there are three
European investigations underway
yep
when any one of those may be concluded
I'd have to refer you to those three
countries is the U.S actively
investigating no who did it why not that
there are three European countries that
have uh
embarked on Independent investigations
of this and were comfortable in their
ability to take a hard look at this and
to come up with conclusions so there
were there's this gas pipeline situation
there's the Drone attack in Moscow a few
weeks ago there's the missile attacks in
Alaska is it afraid to say Ukraine
itself may be doing a lot more of these
more Brazen things than the US is
willing to admit I'll let Ukraine speak
to their activities what what I can tell
you Ed we've said it before we don't
support attacks inside Russia and we
don't encourage or enable Ukraine to be
able to do that we've made those
concerns known to Ukrainian officials
certainly privately absolutely publicly
and we've rece received assurances in
return on the other issue I wanted to
ask about does the bind Administration
have any concern with a major U.S Sports
League getting into business with the
Saudi public investment fund I think
we'll we'll let uh we'll let the Saudi
government speak to that
connect Russian Villages and cut off a
water supply to
Crimea I mean that doesn't seem awful
excuse about it as logical as blowing up
one's own pipeline doesn't it we've come
to no conclusions on this we're working
with ukrainians we'll try to get as much
information as we can okay one more
question
um French and German leaders have called
for new elections and costs about given
the low voter turnout it's causing a lot
of tension what's U.S position on that
I think it will have to get back to you
refer you to the state department but
I'm happy to take that question back I
mean obviously we support free and fair
elections uh everywhere they're uh
they're held but I don't have anything
specific on that another question this
time when Africa is the president's
still on tap to go to the continent
um later this year I don't have anything
on the calendar April but the president
is absolutely intent on visiting Africa
as he said he would and I don't just
don't have any uh I don't have a trip
scheduled to speak to right now it is
still planned to have he still it tends
to visit the continent absolutely
just one more quick follow-up uh event
over the weekend I know you said DOD is
investigating it I don't know did not
say they're investigating it
no I'm not I didn't even say that it is
common practice when DOD conducts an
operation for them to to take a look and
just walk through you know walk through
sort of a hot wash of it
um I'll let them speak to whether
they're doing that and what that looks
like
um
on it is you know if you look at the
timing and the data from the plane it
seems like the intercept happened after
the plane had flown over Washington DC
was that uh from your understanding an
intentional choice or was that an issue
of planes catching up and trying to get
there I don't know I'd refer you to DOD
John on the damn explosion specifically
can you just speak to the president's
engagement on this when he was briefed
and is one of the steps here that he is
ordering the declassification of some of
the information that would help be able
to reveal publicly who the U.S suspects
was behind this now the president was
certainly kept informed of uh of the
event earlier this morning I don't have
the tick tock uh for you on that
um and I know of no decision to to
downgrade anything at this point and
then separately on we understand
secretary blinken will be traveling to
China in the coming weeks after of
course the visit that was canceled
earlier this year can you speak to the
U.S officials who were there in the last
couple of days what role they may have
played in trying to finalize this trip
that had been tried to be rescheduled
certainly one of the purposes of uh of
uh Dan and Sarah's trip was to uh to get
as I said yesterday to make sure the
lines of communication remain open and
to talk about the potential for future
visits higher level visits I think I
said that yesterday
um and uh and they felt that they had
good useful conversations with PRC
officials about that and to that end and
I think you'll see us speak to uh to
Future visits here in the near future
but I just don't want to get ahead of
the schedule
[Music]
M16 fighter jets he said that us both
F-16 fighter jets can accommodate
nuclear weapons and won't apply and keep
with them will escalate the conflict
further to have a response the first
thing I would say to minister lavrov is
if you're worried about the Ukrainian
military capabilities then you should
take your troops and leave Ukraine uh
number two uh these f-16s are going to
be provided as a part of long-term
defense needs for Ukraine we've been
very very open and transparent about
that uh it'll take some time for those
Jets to get there we're going to start
with a training program for Ukrainian
pilots and that hasn't started yet and
it really is about helping Ukraine with
its self-defense needs and the last
thing I'd say is that President Biden
has been extremely consistent that that
we don't want to see this war escalate
certainly not into the nuclear realm and
it's not the United States who's tossing
around Reckless nuclear rhetoric it's
people like foreign minister lavrov and
President Putin and and and Putin's
press secretary peskov they're the ones
that are out there bannering around
about nuclear capabilities not the
United States nobody wants to see this
escalate Beyond uh the violence is
already visited upon the Ukrainian
people there's no reason for that
cannot accommodate everyone
I'm going to talk about the nuclear
capable
capable warm in the American Arsenal the
purpose of providing advanced fighter
aircraft is to help Ukraine defend
itself defend its its uh its airspace
and its territorial Integrity period And
there's no interest by the United States
in escalating this conflict certainly
not into the nuclear Realm
so much on the on the dam in Ukraine I
understand it's it's too early you say
to assess who's responsible for it but
can you already say that until my feet
this will qualify as a war crime I don't
have a determination on that to speak to
today
um I would just say you know again
um without we we're still trying to
assess what happened here but the
Russians had illegally taken over uh
that dam in the reservoir many many
months ago and they were occupying it
when this explosion happened and it's
very clear that the deliberate
destruction of Civilian infrastructure
is not allowed by the laws of war and in
the additional protocol to the Geneva
Convention that the Russians have
themselves signed the destruction of
Civilian infrastructure such as dams and
dams are clearly articulate in there
violations of that code but again we
haven't made a decision we're still
talking to the game it's about this
excuse me did your previous response to
Ed's question on the golf leaks mean
that the White House has no position on
today's announced merger between I don't
have anything to to say about that today
I'm I'm just I have no comment on that
today
the administration position that you do
not support attacks inside of Russia I'm
wondering if the Administration has
communicated that there would be any
potential consequences to Ukraine if
attacks like that do continue for
instance have you made
um military aid conditional on
preventing some of those attacks or is
Russia on the hook here because this is
an illegal invasion
well
as I said earlier if Russia is concerned
about Ukrainian military capabilities
the best thing that they can do would be
to leave Ukraine we have made our
concerns about strikes inside Russia
very clear to Ukrainian officials
they've acknowledged that we have and
they have assured us that they won't use
U.S made equipment to to strike inside
Russia we don't want to see the war
escalate and and there's no apologies
for that
um but I won't go into detail about the
private discussions that we're having
with with ukrainians so you can't tell
us whether or not other than other than
expressing you don't want an escalation
you can't tell us if there's any oh this
is the repercussions look I mean I think
just take a look at everything we've
done in the last 15 months and I
guarantee you you're going to see
additional security assistance packages
in coming days and weeks we're going to
continue to make sure that Ukraine can
succeed on the battlefield as President
Biden has said for as long as it takes
John yesterday when the Danish Prime
Minister was here you reiterated that
the president does not
yet settled on a candidate to be the
next Secretary General of NATO but you
also went out of your way to praise
Secretary General stoltenberg on the job
that he's done does the president by
chance want the Secretary General to
extend his term another year given
everything that's going on in Europe
Secretary General has done a superb job
and particularly at a unbelievably
critical time uh in uh in history
particularly on the European continent
but the president has not settled on
um
a candidate as the next Secretary
General and I just won't get ahead of
his decision-making the president has
made no decisions with respect to uh the
the position of the NATO Secretary
General
pressuring General Secretary General
made no decisions well one way or
whatsoever for figuring that out the
NATO Summit is in July is it important
for you know when all the leaders come
together for there to be some clarity I
think we all know I mean the timelines
really driven more by you know the
secretary General's tenure which
obviously this latest extension is is uh
is coming to a close and so that's
that's going to be driving the
discussions inside the alliance but
president hasn't made one a decision one
way or the other
question
in regards to Chinese incursions in the
indo-pacific
uh what should you say to those who are
criticism the both parties the United
States and China that are acting poorly
on instigating actually escalation what
would what will this Administration do
to lower those tensions in the
indo-pacific well we've been talking
about it now for two days trying to keep
the lines of communication open having a
visit uh to Beijing just this week to
see if we can't get more transparency
and get more communication open
including through the military to
military Lanes
um what are we doing I mean secretary
Austin uh again attempted to have a
discussion with his uh with his
counterpart in the in the PLA and and
they rebuff that so
um to those saying we're not doing
enough it's interesting you're
criticizing or not you but people are
criticizing us for not doing enough and
then I hear from others uh you know
we're doing too much we're bowing down
to China that we're trying too hard I
mean I I think anybody that's taking a
look at this bilateral relationship the
most constant sequential bilateral
relationship in the world right now can
see that the tensions are high and we
all want to see the tensions come down
and the president believes that the best
way to do that is through diplomacy and
it boggles my mind that anybody anywhere
would think a that we're not engaging in
diplomacy and B that diplomacy and the
use of it and the attempt at dialogue
and diplomacy is somehow weakness it
just absolutely boggles my mind we're
working on this very very hard and the
president's confident that we'll be able
to get back to the spirit of Bali
between the PRC and the United States
thanks everybody Mauritius yeah
all right
okay okay
that John doesn't have any comments on
the golf merger but I want to see you
and a comments that what I was concerns
about Saudis human rights record now you
have emerging in an American PGA and the
saudi-back look for what are the
feelings look I I'm
certainly I'm going to be in line with
my NSC colleague and say the same I'm
not going to be commenting
on on that particular merger so we don't
just have don't have anything to to
share at this time uh but uh you know
when it comes to human rights as we have
said over and over again this is
something that the president has been
very clear about and has brought that up
uh with leaders that he's met with and
so that is never anything that we shy
away from but on this particular merger
we're just not going to comment from
here
once in one thing because I don't think
Kirby mentioned this specifically has
the president spoken to president
zielinski about the explosion at the dam
or did they plan to talk today I mean I
know they talked frequently yeah I was
going to say as you know they talk
frequently we talk to their team pretty
frequently uh especially over the last
15 uh 15 months don't have a call to
read out with President zielinski uh
that the the president uh would have had
just don't have anything at this time to
share just
just
succeed in the courts but as it plays
out in the courts How concerned are you
about the impact that this will have on
uh present Biden's efforts to lower drug
prices
look we're going to continue I I laid
out kind of our position on on Merck and
the lawsuit we're always going to be
very careful on commenting on an ongoing
lawsuit but I will say that we're going
to continue it's not going to stop the
president from continuing to to lower
prices uh for the for for Americans
especially health care costs as we've
seen him do with the inflation reduction
act which is a historic piece of
legislation as we talk about uh you know
making sure that we are low in cost for
Americans making sure that insulin is at
35 bucks that's something that came out
for seniors it's something that came out
of that piece of legislation so we are
just going to continue to do the work uh
that's something that the president has
made when it comes to lowering costs his
number one priority is in economic
policy is to do just that so we're going
to let the uh the lawsuit and and that
process go and and continue but we feel
very confident and we're going to
continue doing our work here
for more litigation of things by the end
of this year well I'm certainly not
going to get ahead of of what doj might
be doing not going to get into
hypotheticals from here but what we can
say is that we are confident and we're
certainly going to continue to do the
the work that we have been doing the
last two years uh that the president has
been doing the last two years uh to
lower costs for Americans and American
families and you've seen that we have
actually executed on doing that the
president has with the historic pieces
of legislation that we've gotten done
done okay thanks Merck uh says that the
Medicare drug price negotiation
provision is going to hurt their ability
to invest in developing new drugs
um are you guys confident that this will
not have uh that impact and if not why
not so look I mean for a long time uh
farmer Pharma lobbyist has uh has block
efforts to let Medicare negotiate lower
drug costs and why is that right that is
a question for them why would they block
something that is actually going to help
Americans that is actually going to and
I had mentioned at the top some of these
drugs are decades AIDS you know decades
old and so look we're going to do we're
going to do our job we're going to let
the doj do their job the president's
going to continue he's never going to
stop and putting forward legislation or
policies that's actually going to make
sense for American families make sense
for our seniors makes sense for
Americans who truly need a health care
so that's just not going to stop and
we've talked about big Pharma we've
talked about pharmaceutical gains we've
talked about the record profits that
they that they're able uh to uh to to
get and and they're doing it all on the
backs of many of them on the backs of
middle class families and the president
is saying no we need an economy that
works for all that leaves no one behind
that has Equity at the center of it and
this is part of but this is part of his
plan is there any risk though to their
ability to innovate and to create these
life-saving drugs I I look I you know I
can't speak for them I know that's what
they're laying out we believe that when
it comes to drug prices we believe that
families in amer Americans should be
able to not have to struggle not have to
go bankrupt to to pay for a drug that
they need that's going to save their
lives or save someone that they love and
so that is the that's the focus that
this President is going to have what can
we do to make you talk we talk about
giving families a little bit of
breathing room and that's what the
president's going to focus on
all right good are you concerned that
other drug companies might now follow
Mark's weed and biosity so look I can't
speak for other drug companies not gonna
speak for them here what I can speak to
is what the president's going to
continue to do and that is make sure
that we deliver for American families
make sure that we lower cost that has
been something that I've that we have
said the president have says for some
time when it comes to his Economic
Policy the number one component of that
is how do we continue to lower costs for
Americans
um
today blocking uh quick releases of
migrants does the administration plan to
appeal to the Supreme Court it's ongoing
litigation so certainly I'm not going to
comment on that at this time New York
city mayor floated plans to have
rents behalf housed with residents is
that something the administration would
support and if that ends up becoming
necessary would that be a poor
reflection on the administration's
ability to manage so I haven't seen
those reports I kind of saw some chirons
on on the Cable News Network I think
yours uh coming out to the podium what I
can say is that we have been in touch
with the interior cities right the
cities uh like New York City like
Chicago and others who are dealing with
this issue and we've we've had
conversations with them we are in touch
with them as you know there is a more
than 200 million dollars in funding that
has gone to these interior interior
cities a majority of that has gone to
New York City but just not going to
speak to the mayor's policies I just
don't know much enough about it to speak
to it at this time and the retirements
of coming the Border Chief and the ice
the ice Chief is that going to impact
the administration's ability to manage
the Border in the near term so look um I
from what I understand their retirements
was uh was uh has been planned for some
time now uh and uh and so just gonna
leave that piece to them and certainly
they can speak uh to uh to their
retirement what I can speak to is what
we have seen these past couple of weeks
since the title 42 has been lifted we
have seen uh we've seen legal migration
go down go down significantly and that's
because of the plan that this president
has put forward you think about
diplomacy you think about deterrence you
think about making sure that we're
expanding legal Pathways that's what the
president his administration has been
able to do and that's why we have seen
such a decline at the border and I think
that speaks to the president's
leadership and what he's been able to do
with his team and I think that's
incredibly important real quick though
this whistleblower report alleging that
the U.S military has been retrieving
craft of non-human origin for at least
several decades
are we alone and if we were not would
you even tell us I would refer that
question to the Department of Defense
and let them answer that question for
you go ahead back on the Murphy just a
little bit uh you said at the top that
there's nothing in the Constitution that
prevents Medicare from negotiating the
lawyers for Mark are arguing that it
violates the fifth amendment that taking
its Clause the first amendment is too
coercive if you have a specific response
to those I don't have a response to that
I can just say clearly there's gonna
there's a lawsuit uh there'll be little
clearly as being litigated I will leave
it to uh I'll leave it to the Department
of Justice to deal with I've been very
clear that it is in the Constitution to
do what it is that we're moving forward
with this is a piece of legislation
clearly that was passed the president
signed into law and it's going to help
American families it's going to help
Americans that really truly need it we
should not be in a situation in 2023
where you have American families who are
sitting around the kitchen table every
month trying to figure out how are they
going to pay a for these uh for these
bills and how they're what is it that
they're going to cut so that they can't
get a drug that is life-saving and that
is something that the president is aware
of you hear him talk about he's talked
about his his how he grew up and how
those conversations are incredibly
difficult and so this is what the
president's been talking about right
making sure again we don't leave anybody
behind we have Equity at everything that
we do and that we have an economy that
grows from the middle up and the
bottom-up middle out and that's the pr
the president's plan he's going to stick
to it got April
um on Mississippi Jackson Mississippi in
this 115 million towards repairing their
water infrastructure Mississippi isn't
alone
bill has infrastructure problems
problems um what's happening not just
with Mississippi but also with Flint as
you're in these efforts to repair no
it's a good question and certainly EPA
is is going to be running this process
so I would refer you to specific
programs on this particular 115 million
dollars that we announced today so this
is an initial investment let me just say
that first that the president fought for
and that was secured and that's over 600
million from Congress for the city's
water system as we talk about
specifically on Jackson and in the
fiscal year 2023 Government funding bill
that's where that's coming from and so
it is on top of tens of millions of
dollars we've already deployed as it
relates to the city and let's not forget
this is this is through the president's
bipartisan infrastructure law and so and
also the American Rescue plan so because
of these two pieces of historic
legislation one was bipartisan one was
the American Rescue plan was just by
Democrat to pushed that along and the
president's first major piece of
legislation they're going to help cities
like Flint it's going to help as I just
mentioned Jackson and so this is really
important right as we talk about how
we're moving forward as a country our
our economic system how we're going to
make sure that we take care of areas
like this that have been left behind
that has not have had any really much
investment to deal with the water
situation that they're having to deal
with this is why it's so important that
we have the infrastructure lies why
we're so important that we're get we're
able to get the American Rescue plan as
it relates to Flint I would refer you to
the EPA will they have more information
and how these two pieces of historic
legislation are are going to be deployed
and helped in Flint the broader piece
though Beyond Flint Beyond Mississippi
this is a nation that has a lot of
antiquated systems underneath so you're
saying that this will be more broad oh
absolutely I think that's why again
that's why the Bible person
infrastructure law is so critical
because it is meant to more broadly deal
with communities just like this and
other communities as well as they deal
with uh you know as they deal with the
water system as they deal with you know
broken roads as they deal with trying to
fix you know their Bridges all of the
things that is so important let's not
forget this is a president who has said
when it comes to these infrastructure
bill or that is now law clearly it's
about the decade right infrastructure
for a decade it is uh incredibly
important and it's going to change lives
for Americans across the country
merger would be subject to Federal
regulatory oversight from like the FTC
or doj so I'm just not going to get into
it from here I'm just not
go ahead go ahead thank you Kareem
um
I want to ask about the president's
tumble that he took on the stage in
Colorado the other day
um it's absolutely true that any one of
us could trip over a
an object just happens to be in our path
nonetheless we've all observed the
difficulty this president has in certain
settings steps are one of them
and of course there was no sandbag in
his path on the steps up Air Force One
on any of those occasions
and I was struck particularly by the
incident on May 19 in Hiroshima where
the president descended down a set of
stone steps towards shrine at the bottom
of which steps he was greeted by the
Japanese prime minister and if you look
at that footage the president slipped
and caught himself on those steps
and as he greeted the Prime Minister you
could even see on the president's face
purse lips as if to say this was a close
one and I know I watched that scene with
my heart in my hands because this was a
set of stone steps and even though there
were handrails on either side he was
directed by his Advanced team presumably
to descend at the middle of those steps
unaided by the handrails the Japanese
prime minister and Aid or anything else
um and that could have been really
catastrophic and so my question to you
is whether this whole series of
incidents has led the white house chief
of staff to direct some kind of review
of the advanced procedures that are
employed on behalf of this the nation's
oldest president so let me say you've
paid a lot of attention to that
particular situation I I actually
did not see that I was with him in
Hiroshima so this is something that I
was not aware of so I can't speak to
that particular particular moment
um you know here's what I will say
um this is a president
um
you know that has
had an incredibly impressive first two
years
when you think about what he's been able
to get done
when you think about
the record historic pieces of
legislation that are now into law I just
went into went into it with the
different pieces of of legislation
that's actually going to make a
difference and change Americans lives
Americans who truly need it
and that's I think is what the American
people are looking for they're looking
for someone that can actually deliver
like that that the president has done
and even last week when you think about
the budget negotiations you heard you
heard from uh you heard from Republicans
Congressional Republicans ranging from
the right Maga and members to speaker
McCarthy emphasize the president's
smarts and capabilities in in making
sure that there was a bipartisan
reasonable Common Sense piece of
legislation a fiscally responsible piece
of legislation that is going to help
American families and so you see him
again and again and again over the past
few years deliver whether it's 2020
where people underestimated him and he
got that done whether it's 2022 again
when people uh when people
underestimated got that done whether
it's this budget agreement he got that
done and I think that is the most
important thing that the Americans are
going to care about and that Americans
are going to look to and
um so I will I will leave that there
Americans are looking at I'm asking
about it that is that what it's
important as a reporter don't you think
it's important what Americans care about
my questions but my question was I'm
just saying that is something that
Americans want isn't that not not true
that that they have a leader that's
going to deliver for them may or may not
be true but it's not responsive to my
question I think it's very true you're
asking no I know what your question is
you're asking me if we're going to
change anything from here the chief of
staff has asked for it to change
anything from here and and here's the
thing here's the thing
we are not
things happen other presidents have had
similar situations as you know and I'm
sure you've reported on the last
president who's had a similar situation
and so look things happen this is a
president that delivers and will
continue to deliver for the American
people and that's what he cares about
I'll see you guys tomorrow thank you
thank you